[MUSIC PLAYING]
AL SEALES: Hey,
everybody, welcome to yet
another installment of our
Broadway at Google series
with "Pippin"!
Yes.
So I'm Al Seales with the
Talks at Google program.
And thank you all
very much for coming.
So "Pippin," back on Broadway
for the first time since it
thrilled audience
40 years ago, now
won the Tony award for
best musical revival.
A beloved score by Tony nominee
Stephen Schwartz, "Pippin"
tells a story of a young prince
on a death-defying journey
to find meaning
in his existence.
So now, to get us started
off, please welcome Kyle Dean
Massey.
[MUSIC - PIPPIN, "CORNER OF THE
SKY"]
[APPLAUSE]
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Thanks,
this is Bethany Moore.
BETHANY MOORE: Hello.
[MUSIC - PIPPIN, "KIND OF
WOMAN"]
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - PIPPIN, "LOVE SONG"]
BETHANY MOORE: And now,
our leading player,
Mrs. Ciara Renee.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - PIPPIN, "SIMPLE JOYS"]
CIARA RENEE: Well,
thanks, thank you.
Now, we're going to bring up one
of our amazing actor/acrobats,
Orion Griffiths.
[APPLAUSE]
That's right, give
it up, come on!
[CIRCUS MUSIC]
Ha!
[APPLAUSE]
CIARA RENEE: Ladies, and
gentlemen, feast your eyes
on the most difficult and
intricate balancing act.
Behold, the reckless
[INAUDIBLE],
the Rolla Bolla Man!
Only he can perform
such feats as this.
Yeah, give it up!
Let's go!
[APPLAUSE]
Orion Griffiths!
AL SEALES: Give everybody
another round of applause!
That was amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
Wow.
So to help me chat
with these folks
here in a second-- you can
bring the chairs up, yeah.
We are going to bring
up Mark Douglas.
Mark Douglas is a New
York City comedian
who works as one of the
two writer/performers
on the Barely Political YouTube
channel, where the videos have
been viewed $2 billion times.
The channel's most
popular series, Kielbasa,
made up entirely of funny songs,
both original, and parody.
He also works at Google.
So please, welcome
Mark to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
MARK DOUGLAS: Hey,
does this work?
OK, good.
AL SEALES: Yes.
And then the rest--
bring the cast up, too.
I don't want to just
talk to Mark up here.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, we
are not nearly as talented
as you guys I could do that
thing with the cylinders,
but I just don't feel like it.
AL SEALES: Yeah, I guess
we should all take a seat.
That's the idea.
There we go.
So wow, Orion.
You are one of the few
people in the world who
can do that balancing act
with five cylinders, right?
ORION GRIFFITHS: One
of the few people
that can do a handstand
on the five cylinders.
MARK DOUGLAS: He's probably
one of the only people that
wants to do it.
[LAUGHTER]
So that kind of like narrows it
down a little bit right there.
ORION GRIFFITHS: It
does a little bit, yeah,
because nobody else is
stupid enough to do it.
AL SEALES: You don't have a mic?
I'll give you one.
ORION GRIFFITHS:
[INAUDIBLE] lean in.
MARK DOUGLAS: No,
mics for everyone.
AL SEALES: So before we get into
this, let's go down the line
and just briefly
introduce yourselves
and say what you
do with the show.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I'll start.
Oh, OK, never mind.
ORION GRIFFITHS: You're
more important than me.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I'm Kyle
Dean Massey, and I play Pippin.
BETHANY MOORE: Oh,
can I borrow that?
My name is Bethany Moore,
and I'm one of the players.
And I understudy Catherine.
She's the chicken, guys.
CIARA RENEE: My
name is Ciara Renee.
And I am playing leading player.
ORION GRIFFITHS: My
name's Orion Griffiths,
and I really don't
know what I do.
CIARA RENEE: He's
Rolla Bolla man.
ORION GRIFFITHS: I'm
one of the acrobats.
And I do acrobatics, and
cylinder stuff in the show.
AL SEALES: So I don't
want to focus on this,
it just amazes me.
The cylinder act, how long
did you train for that?
What's your background
in life in general?
ORION GRIFFITHS: Uh,
background in life--
that's a good question.
I was born into a family
circus, a small family circus--
mom and dad, eight kids--
MARK DOUGLAS: Not the
comic strip, right?
ORION GRIFFITHS: What?
MARK DOUGLAS: Not
the comic strip?
ORION GRIFFITHS:
No, the real deal.
My world.
Yeah no, I started training
that when I was six years old,
the cylinders thing.
AL SEALES: So you're
one of how many sibling?
ORION GRIFFITHS:
I'm one of eight.
AL SEALES: Wow, and can
they all do handstands?
ORION GRIFFITHS:
They all can, yes.
Some are jugglers, handstands,
and tumblers, yeah.
AL SEALES: Wow.
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah.
AL SEALES: Well OK, so--
ORION GRIFFITHS: No
more questions, huh?
AL SEALES: I could talk
about that all day.
So Kyle Dean--
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Yeah.
AL SEALES: Congratulations
on your now third week
of performances in
the show, correct?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
Yeah, thank you.
AL SEALES: So this is
obviously a little bit more
of a physically demanding
show than, perhaps, roles
in the past.
Like, what did you have to do,
I guess, to prepare for this?
To addition for it?
Like, I have no idea
where to start with this.
This show is so different.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
Yeah, it is different.
Well, most times, when you're a
replacement in the show like I
am in the show,
like, they usually
give you two weeks,
sometimes three
if you're lucky
to learn the role
and to get put into the show.
And they gave five weeks with
this show, which I've never
rehearsed that long
for a replacement.
But we had to do all
kinds of other things.
Like, I had to learn how
to throw knives and do
a backflip-- which Orion
catches me almost every night--
climbing poles, and doing all
kinds of things that I've never
done before,
playing the guitar--
AL SEALES: Did you
actually play that?
That was you playing?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Well,
not in that track there.
That's why we look like
schmucks singing it.
Because we're normally
sitting on the ground, and I
have a guitar that I'm playing.
So I'm like, what do
I with my hands now.
But it was great
because we got some time
to build up our stamina
and kind of learn
what it takes to do the show.
But I'm not going to lie.
The first week was really tough.
It was really tough.
MARK DOUGLAS: How does that
work with integrating you
into a cast that's
already working.
I don't know anything
about how this works.
But I feel like, do
you have to rehearse
with the cast that's
already doing it?
Or how do you--?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I mean,
they're working at night.
So I mean, every once in awhile,
the cast will get called in.
They were very kind to us,
and they called everybody
in a couple times.
But most of the time-- Ciara and
I came into the show together.
So we rehearsed together at a
rehearsal studio with the stage
manager on the stage
when there wasn't a show.
And then they do what
they call put in.
So it's usually a couple
days before your first show,
where the entire cast is called,
and you run the entire show
from beginning to end.
You're the only
people in costume.
And sometimes you get lights.
Sometimes you get, like, a
drummer, or the full orchestra,
depending on how
fancy they want to be.
But you kind of get a dry run.
So there've been
some shows where
I haven't met the entire
cast until my put in.
MARK DOUGLAS: Oh wow.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: There
have been times where that--
MARK DOUGLAS: Put in, that
sounds very technical.
Yeah, I mean-- for people
that have not seen this show,
it is incredible.
It was sort of like--
I was telling Ciara
that when I describe this show,
I sound like that guy Stefon.
Like, this has everything--
talking severed head, fire,
Annie Potts-- you
know, that thing where
a muscle man gets
on the cylinders?
But it really does
have everything.
And I mean, I'm just blown away.
Like, I make YouTube videos,
and I feel like I'm in the arts.
But you guys are bringing it.
And it's amazing because
there's so much to watch.
You kind of throw down
the gauntlet, saying,
we've got magic to do.
And then you do
it in every form.
And it's just really incredible.
If you haven't seen
it, please go see it.
That feels like the end of
the interview, doesn't it?
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, I've got to go.
I've got OKRs.
[LAUGHTER]
That wasn't a question.
I just wanted to bow down
to them for a moment.
AL SEALES: So Ciara,
you're also three weeks in.
You got put in the
same time, right?
So was your experience the same?
You see a lot of shows.
And the leads, they don't
do all of the dancing.
And they don't do
all of the numbers
because it's just so physically
demanding night after night.
But you guys are
doing the acrobatics.
And you're jumping, like,
20 feet off the ground.
Kyle Dean is jumping from
pole, to stage, platform,
and this stuff, like-- how
was that the first time you
started doing this?
CIARA RENEE: OK,
well the first thing
they had me do, before I
started any rehearsals,
was to do trapeze.
They sent me on to
Circus Warehouse,
and they were like, we need to
make sure that you can do this.
Because, I mean, it's crazy.
I never, in a million
years, thought
that I would be learning
how to do the trapeze.
And at first, it was absolutely
terrifying, and so painful,
and I was like, I
don't want to do it.
But now I absolutely love it.
And I feel like I'm, like, a
quarter cool as you, or maybe
like an eighteenth,
or something.
But yeah, no, it was
really, really difficult.
It's probably the hardest
thing I've ever done.
But it is super, super fun.
AL SEALES: So you
have no safety net.
CIARA RENEE: No.
There I am.
That's why I have been working
out every single day because I
want to be able to catch myself
if I fall out of something,
you know?
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
it seems like there's
nobody in the cast
who gets off easy.
Like, I saw Annie Potts.
I was like, OK, they won't
make her get up on the trapeze.
And then there she is.
And she's in amazing shape.
But do you ever make her say,
Ghostbusters, what do you want?
[LAUGHTER]
CIARA RENEE: I want to, I know.
MARK DOUGLAS: Is
she cool about that?
ORION GRIFFITHS: I think
she would just leave.
I'm leaving.
MARK DOUGLAS: So you had never
played the guitar before?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I had played,
like, chords and things.
But playing, and singing,
and acting at the same time
is completely different.
And, like, finger picking
is what I'm doing.
And so they put me
into guitar lessons.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
One of the great things I
feel like, probably, for you
guys is, after this show,
the next thing you do
will probably be much easier.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
Without a doubt.
MARK DOUGLAS: It was kind
of nice to see you guys
actually sing the songs and
kind of appreciate just the song
because there's so much
going on behind you.
It's kind of like
a Broadway show
with a real circus behind it.
But it was really cool to
see you guys kind just, oh,
these songs are
really good, too.
It's like there's Easter eggs.
At one point, you did a
magic trick back there
during the show with the whole--
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Yeah.
CIARA RENEE: Who?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
The levitation.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CIARA RENEE: I do.
MARK DOUGLAS: You
don't even remember.
CIARA RENEE: My brain is fried.
All of the magic tricks I do.
I don't know.
MARK DOUGLAS: When you go
and audition for something
like this, is it just the song?
Or do they go, OK,
you did the song,
now do a backflip
and all that stuff?
Or is it kind of--?
CIARA RENEE: No,
they didn't expect
us to know how to
do those things.
We were really lucky
that they really
taught us all of the magic
tricks, all of the acrobatics,
all of the dance,
stuff like that.
I mean, dance was part of
our audition, and the scenes,
and everything like that.
It was a pretty
standard audition.
But then, afterwards, they
were like-- the first thing
you need to start doing
right now trapeze,
and this, and that,
and this and that,
all the magic tricks
and stuff like that.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
Yeah, because we
have circus training every day.
And we still have it for
an hour before the show.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: And we
have a separate circus
trainer named Tony.
CIARA RENEE: Yeah,
Tony Hernandez,
who is really incredible
and takes a lot of time
with both of us
because we need it.
MARK DOUGLAS: How's it
working with that dog?
[LAUGHTER]
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: That
was another thing.
Yeah, well that thing is really
like our dog trainer, actually.
BETHANY MOORE: I trained dogs
before I got into theater.
So that was kind of lucky.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
So random, right?
BETHANY MOORE: So random.
On our resumes, we put special
skills of the very bottom,
and, like, ballroom dancing,
or something random like that.
And I put dog show
handling and dog trainer.
And our director, Diane Paulus
said, oh, so you do train dogs?
Would you mind doing
that on Broadway?
Well, of course.
So that was really--
MARK DOUGLAS: And
that got you the part?
BETHANY MOORE: Well, hopefully.
CIARA RENEE: That's
the only reason.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Every
little bit helps, right?
BETHANY MOORE: Every
little bit helps, though.
But yeah, our dog right
now, his name is Barnum.
Ha, ha, funny, the circus.
And one of the most
fun I've had was
working with Barnum and
Kyle Dean at the same time
because they are put
ins for the same show.
So we were training both
of them at the same time.
[LAUGH]
AL SEALES: Do you ever
have to tap on the ground
to get Kyle Dean to go
where he needs to go?
BETHANY MOORE: Come on, cookie.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
I like treats, too.
MARK DOUGLAS: He won't
hit that last note
unless you give
him a little snack.
AL SEALES: So Bethany and Orion,
you guys have been in the show
since it was-- I can't
say the beginning.
I mean, the beginning
of the revival.
BETHANY MOORE:
Before the beginning.
The workshops, and Boston,
out of town tryout and--
AL SEALES: So how did that
process work because I know,
with new shows, they go through
all the script revisions,
and the scene
changes, and they cut
whole numbers, and whole
characters, in some points.
But, like, this was a
well established, I guess,
oiled machine from
the '70s, right?
So then how did it work
bringing it back this time?
BETHANY MOORE: Well, I think
the biggest challenge was
to really bring circus,
and the Fosse style,
and the whole story telling
aspect together and really
making it seamless.
And I think that is what
the workshops, like, that is
what it was all about.
And the acrobats had
to do Fosse dancing.
And the Fosse dancers had
to do a little acrobatics.
Very, very little.
So it was all about
telling the story.
And it was pushing
the story along
and Diane Paulus wouldn't let
anything happen on the stage
unless you could answer why.
Why would you do that there?
Why put the trick there?
And I think that is what
made this show so brilliant,
and seamless, and a
beautiful circus Fosse piece.
AL SEALES: So there was this
stuff that was tried initially
that eventually got dropped?
ORION GRIFFITHS: There was a lot
of acrobatics that got dropped.
When I first came to the
show, I got a call to do it.
And I was like, well, yeah,
I'll come, and I came.
And I showed them
my Rolla Bolla.
And they had no idea.
They were like, well,
what's Rolla Bolla?
And I was like,
well, I'll show you.
And Diane was like,
wow, I don't know
if we can put that in there.
I was like, just watch.
And she was like, all right,
yeah, that's going in.
That's going in, yeah.
You're going to open the
second act with that.
And that managed to stay.
But there was a lot
of acrobatic tricks
that got dropped that didn't
make sense to the show.
Let's say, in
Extraordinary, we used
to do Russian bar, which is a
bar that goes from one shoulder
to somebody else's shoulder.
And somebody stands on it,
and they flip really high.
But it was taking too much
attention away from the story.
So it just didn't make sense.
The whole audience would
be, like, whoa, whoa?
And Pippin would be like--
I didn't make any sense.
I'm extraordinary, not him.
So stuff like that had
to be cut, you know?
MARK DOUGLAS: So, I don't know
if you want to talk about this.
But we heard that you had
an injury during rehearsals.
ORION GRIFFITHS: No,
I never get hurt.
Yeah, I broke my back.
I snapped it right
through the middle.
MARK DOUGLAS: Was it
doing the Rolla Bolla?
ORION GRIFFITHS: No, it was
doing an acrobatic trick.
We were in the
middle of rehearsing.
We were doing 12 hour days.
And I was doing
an acrobatic trick
with another guy,
Yannick, original cast,
and I was doing like a
back flip off of him.
And something
happened, [INAUDIBLE].
And I ended up breaking my back.
And I stood up.
I was like, oh man,
that didn't feel right.
And then, like, a few weeks
down the line, I was like, whoa,
this is not getting any better.
And I started to sweat a lot.
And then, like,
a month in, I was
like, oh, I might have
to go to the doctor.
So I went next month.
And then it was two months.
And then I went to the doctor.
And he did the MRI.
And then I didn't go back to
the MRI for another three weeks.
And the doctor called me
and was like, hey, you're
back is broken.
I was like, huh?
[LAUGHTER]
It's really funny.
And he was like, you need
to come out the show now
because it wasn't healing.
It was moving.
Every time I do a
big trick, and, yeah,
it was like [CRUNCHING NOISE].
MARK DOUGLAS: I hate
when that happens.
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah, so
they stuck me in brace,
and they were like, you're
done, you're finished.
You might never tumble again.
And four months later,
I made a full recovery
and came back in the show.
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
Stop it, shut up, stop it.
AL SEALES: So you said you broke
it doing some tumbling that you
don't get to do-- or that you
were rehearsing for something
else, or is it something--
ORION GRIFFITHS: No,
it was in the show.
It's still in the show.
AL SEALES: Oh, good.
MARK DOUGLAS: You do realize
your whole story sounds
like a superhero
back story, right?
Just saying, when this is
done, you could be Batman.
ORION GRIFFITHS: OK, that's
what I'm working towards.
AL SEALES: What else can you do
that we don't see in the show?
I mean, since you were 8, you
said, you've been training?
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah.
AL SEALES: So what else--
what's on your resume?
MARK DOUGLAS: You're not
impressed by the rolly thing?
What else you got?
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah, what
more do you want me to do?
AL SEALES: I want to see if
you can like work here, maybe.
I don't know.
MARK DOUGLAS: I can do this
thing that looks my thumbs
[INAUDIBLE].
ORION GRIFFITHS:
Yeah, it's better
if you never do that again, man.
Um, I can act.
I think I can act.
MARK DOUGLAS: You can, I saw it.
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah, I'm
trying to become an actor.
I switched to
Broadway from circus
because I wanted to be an actor.
CIARA RENEE: He's
doing a great job.
AL SEALES: Yeah, yeah.
CIARA RENEE: He's
doing a real good job.
AL SEALES: For you guys
who are on Broadway,
would you ever consider,
like, a circus career?
How do you equate?
CIARA RENEE: You
just heard the man.
He said he broke his
back, and he kept going.
No, no.
That would be the end of me.
No. [LAUGH] I couldn't imagine.
AL SEALES: So for
Ryan, for you, I
would feel like theater is very
transient in itself anyway.
But, like, circus, I would
feel is even more so.
Is this, like, the first
regular gig, I guess,
regular paycheck
that's been coming in?
ORION GRIFFITHS:
It is, definitely.
When I first came onto the
show, and that first paycheck
came through, I was like, whoa.
Whoa!
Yeah, you know, and I've been
steady on the show for a while
now, and they want to keep me.
But it's definitely the most
regular thing I've ever done.
I've been all around the world
performing with my family,
but I've been hungry.
That's a circus
performer's life.
Going to the doctors
was-- for me to actually
be able to go to the doctors,
they were like, yeah, go.
I was like, oh, that's
going to be too expensive.
They are like, no.
It's called covered.
You've got insurance.
And I was like, all
right, all right, yeah.
So I was too afraid to go.
I would get to the door,
and I'd be waiting for them
to ask me for money.
And they would be
like, you can go now.
I said, what?
OK.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
hesitate to ask this,
but have there been any other
mishaps during performances?
It seems like a--
CIARA RENEE: I mean, maybe not
as major as breaking the back.
But every night,
there's something.
There's always something.
But that's live theater.
MARK DOUGLAS: But it doesn't
seem like a regular show
where-- it looks like there's
zero margin for error.
I mean there's stuff going on
that you have to walk through.
I mean, can you go
through what-- I mean,
what safety precautions are
taken for knife throwing.
Is that just--
BETHANY MOORE: Get
out of the way.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Don't
get hit by the knife.
MARK DOUGLAS: I
mean, is that it?
I mean, is there a
special suit someone's
wearing that's a little, I mean?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: No.
[LAUGH]
ORION GRIFFITHS: Shock suit.
MARK DOUGLAS: No,
but the one lady
has got on kind of a body suit.
And I thought maybe
there was chain mail
in there or something.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
I wear chain mail.
I actually wear
chain mail, but--
CIARA RENEE: No.
MARK DOUGLAS: Wow,
that's pretty incredible.
BETHANY MOORE: Just move.
CIARA RENEE: Just move.
Be aware.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well, you
were in "Spider-Man."
Are you kind of ready to be in a
show that's not insane? [LAUGH]
BETHANY MOORE: Yeah,
well, this actually
feels a little bit more insane.
We're not flying as
high, but we also
don't have any safety
wires in this show.
In "Spider-Man," I got to
do some flying at the very,
very beginning of the show.
And they released
us, and we float
over the audience,
and things like that.
And that was all great.
But there were like two safety
lines on every single person.
And whenever you do
a flip, when people
are jumping through the air,
there there's no safety net.
There's no safety wire.
It is purely dependent
on the people on stage
and not technical things,
which I like better.
Especially with this cast,
we all trust each other more
than any group of people that
I've ever been a part of.
And whenever you work
together this closely,
and you know that
you have to be on,
mentally and physically,
every single night because,
if you're just a
little bit late,
there's somebody
flying through the air
that you could cause an
injury to them or you.
So yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's a little more
reliable than a wire sometimes.
Just that you care.
BETHANY MOORE: Yeah, what was
it, like a half an inch off,
then the E-stop, the
emergency stop, would go off.
So that's why we had Spider-Man
dangling over the audience
a bunch of times.
We got really used to,
oh, ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to hold.
MARK DOUGLAS: Do you think
shows like "Spider-Man"
kind of upped the ante
for Broadway in general?
Because watching
the show, I felt
like, wow, this is
"Pippin" on steroids.
I mean, I don't know.
I've never seen a production
of "Pippin" before.
But it felt like this was
like the super-duper version.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
I think that's just
the general state of
Broadway, honestly.
I think Broadway
has increasingly
become more spectacular.
And people settle down for
longer runs then they used to.
So they're willing to put more
money into the show to begin.
But I don't know, I think it's
just the audience expect that.
It's not necessarily Broadway.
It's just what people want.
When you're paying that
kind of money to see a show,
people like to see
their money on stage.
They do.
They like to feel
wowed by everything.
You like for it to
hit everywhere--
which I think "Pippin" does.
"Pippin" does very well.
AL SEALES: So if James Cameron
were to direct "Pippin"--
BETHANY MOORE:
"Avatar," the musical.
[LAUGHTER]
AL SEALES: I can imagine an
Avatar doing the handstand
on the Rolla Bollas.
Is that what it's called?
Yeah.
So the technology, obviously,
though, has changed, I guess,
the expectation.
But "Pippin" is
still, like, I guess--
I didn't feel like the set was--
the technology didn't detract
from the story because it's
still very simple at heart.
There was two levels, I
think, at any given time.
And that's really it.
And there's no, like, $70
million LCD screens everywhere.
So the story in
still very solid.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, it felt
like most of the effects
were all man made.
That was what was kind
of refreshing about it.
It was all based on
just human tricks.
There was like
magic of every kind.
Does anybody have any
questions out in the--
AL SEALES: Oh yeah,
if there's questions,
please hit the
aisle microphones.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
It's like "Donahue."
[LAUGHTER]
MARK DOUGLAS: (FUNNY
ACCENT) Yeah, excuse me?
The guy in the green shirt?
AL SEALES: So I
guess this is kind
of a question for all of you.
I mean, you do eight
shows a week, right?
And the show is not
easy, physically.
How do you keep yourself
from just falling over?
BETHANY MOORE: Caffeine.
CIARA RENEE: Adrenaline?
I don't know.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
I just eat a lot.
I have to eat a lot.
I'm not even kidding.
I mean, I have to eat
so much to not crash.
Because I don't ever
leave the stage.
So I have to drink a lot
of water before the act.
We have water hidden for me
on stage in a couple places.
But, you know, once you're on
there, you can't be like, oh,
I've got to go to
the bathroom, y'all.
There's none of that.
MARK DOUGLAS: Is there
a physical warmup?
I mean, I know you've
got to warm up your voice
and hit those
notes, but how long
do you have to take
to sort of warm up
your whole instrument before--?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Well, I
mean, we do training every day.
So yeah.
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah, we
like to be on stage warming up
a whole hour before,
just to warm up.
But we like to train, too.
So we like warm up,
and we're training
as we're warming up, what we
would be doing in the show.
So it's not like we're just
sitting there stretching.
We're also doing what we'd be
doing in the show backstage.
Like running it
before it happens.
So it's a solid hour every
single day before the show.
MARK DOUGLAS: It's not
one you can phone in.
ORION GRIFFITHS: No,
if you don't warm up
when you're an acrobat, you
just really ruin your body.
And I think that's something
Kyle Dean is realizing now,
when you're doing big
tricks every single day--
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I've
been taking a bath
almost every night.
In Epsom salt.
I wake up every day,
and I'm like, oh my god.
MARK DOUGLAS: Is there a tour of
the show that's happening yet?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Yeah,
it's going out in September.
Is that right, Heath?
It begins in September.
It's a national tour.
And it's booked in
several cities already.
I don't know how many
cities it's actually
been revealed in yet, so
I don't think I can say.
But yeah, it's a
full national tour.
MARK DOUGLAS: Are
they going to be
able to do all of the
bells and whistles
and travel that around?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Yes.
Yeah.
AL SEALES: I mean,
Cirque du Soleil
sets up a tent in parking lots.
So this is--
MARK DOUGLAS: I know,
but I'm having trouble
getting my head around it.
There's fire in this show.
AL SEALES: Fire doesn't travel.
MARK DOUGLAS: I don't know.
Do you have to have a guy
with an extinguisher there
are at all times?
ORION GRIFFITHS: We do.
Actually, it's really
funny because you
said there was fire.
Just the other night--
[LAUGHTER]
Two nights ago, the
wicks on the fire
torches, you're
got to change them
every week-- more
like every two weeks
because they burn
down very quickly.
And they wont hold the fuel.
So the fuel will flick off,
and get you in the eye,
and it's hot.
And you're juggling fire.
You're like [IN DISCOMFORT]
just dripping.
And the other night, I had
one of the fire torches.
And the wicks had burned
down a little too much.
And it swiped from my leg.
And my leg caught
on fire right here.
Lucky, lucky--
AL SEALES: And you
are not wearing pants.
ORION GRIFFITHS: No.
Lucky, my left side was
toward the audience.
So all my hair was [WHOOSH].
And I was just like--
nobody noticed.
[LAUGHTER]
Just carried on with show.
AL SEALES: So Ciara,
you, much like Pippin,
are fresh out of college.
This is your second
Broadway show, correct?
Right?
So you were in "Big
Fish," and then now you're
the ringleader in "Pippin."
So I hope you stay in
the show for many years,
and as long as you would like.
But next in your career, what
do you see yourself-- like, what
is your meaty role
that you would
like to just sink
your teeth into?
CIARA RENEE: Oh, I mean, I
want to do a lot of things.
I've always said that
alpha buzz-- like that's
a dream of mine.
It is.
Call me corny, whatever.
I want to do it.
I want to be green and fly.
No, but I mean, I kind
of got a slight taste
of originating with "Big Fish."
I mean, I was late into the
project, so a lot of things
had already been set.
But I still had a lot of freedom
to kind of work around that.
But I would really
like to start working
on more regional projects
and be with something
the whole way through.
And I'm actually working
on a workshop now.
And I like that.
I like being a part of
the creative process
and being a part of the family
from the very beginning.
I mean, it's so amazing
stepping into this group
because they've been so
amazing, and so open,
and it's just a
great mix of people,
with the acrobats and
the theater people
because we're from
totally different worlds
but also very similar.
We have so much in common.
AL SEALES: Everybody get along?
CIARA RENEE: I mean,
that's the thing.
We really do.
There's always going to
be drama and whatever.
We're humans.
But it's really very chill.
And it was really awesome
to step into this group
and it be so warm and open.
But it would also be really
great to be there doing it
from the beginning
and really creating
with a group of people.
So hopefully,
that's what's next.
MARK DOUGLAS: It'd be nice to
see you play somebody nice.
CIARA RENEE: That
would be nice, too.
You know?
Yeah.
MARK DOUGLAS: I was
ready to be scared of you
because you were
really scary up there.
CIARA RENEE: I know.
I've been a scary witch,
and now I'm a scary MC.
I don't know--
MARK DOUGLAS: A lot of the
logic of this play almost
feels like it's kind of taking
place in a dream, in a way.
There's things that kind
of-- spoiler alert--
you stab your father, and
then he comes back to life.
Is there a challenge of
how do you play this?
Do you play this really real?
Or do you play it--
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Yes, 100%.
I'm not even kidding, I dream
about it almost every night
still.
Like, what is
happening in the scene?
What do I--?
Because the premise
of the show is
that we are performers
of a circus troupe.
And we're putting on the show
"Pippin" for you tonight.
And I am a character playing
Pippin in the show of "Pippin."
So there are many
times where you're
like-- am I really Pippin?
Or am I this dude
playing Pippin.
And does Pippin feel this?
Or does the dude playing
Pippin feel this?
Do you know what I mean?
And you're like-- it's hurting
my head to even think about it.
I've figured it out in
moments, but it gives you
a lot of, I guess, kind
of freedom to kind of just
do it differently every night.
MARK DOUGLAS: I'm sure
the director probably
helps a little bit.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: No.
[LAUGHTER]
No, because it's a very
individualistic kind of thing.
I think we've all found
our own things there.
And it's not something that
someone can tell you, well,
that's what it is
because they don't know.
The people that
wrote it don't know.
And I think the
people that watch
the show have their own
personal idea of what
happens with the show.
And that's what we're going for.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah,
it does have a kind
of open campus
sort of feel to it.
It could be so many
different things.
AL SEALES: We have a
question over here.
Yes.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: I was just
wondering-- do you
guys have any kind
of stories that you
go back to that are
like, oh, do you
guys remember that one time?
That all the cast remembers.
Like, oh that one time that
everything was crazy backstage.
Or somebody changed
something up,
and it was totally hilarious--
BETHANY MOORE:
Andrew [INAUDIBLE].
ORION GRIFFITHS: The
curtain was a bust.
In the beginning of
the show, there's
a big curtain that comes down.
And when we were first
starting the show, way back
in Cambridge,
there was something
wrong with the mechanics
of the curtain.
So we'd all be in the background
getting pumped up, you know,
hitting each other--
that's what acrobats do--
pumping each other up, getting
in our big acrobatic tricks.
And then the curtain
is supposed to drop.
And it just doesn't drop.
And we're all like--
stuck, for like a minute.
And it doesn't drop.
And everybody is
just like backstage,
and it happened three times in
the first week of performances.
So every night, we were,
like, is it going to drop?
Is it going to drop?
And then it drops.
And we're like, yeah!
[LAUGHTER]
BETHANY MOORE: Oh
god, I'm trying
to remember a good one to tell.
MARK DOUGLAS: Well,
that was good.
BETHANY MOORE: That
was a really good one.
AL SEALES: That was good.
Got another one?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I was
particularly interested
by you talking
about how individual
and experienced playing
each of characters are.
And I always thought that
was very interesting,
specifically, when you
are not the original cast
of a certain character
because there
might be certain jokes,
or tellings of jokes
that people come to anticipate,
they come to expect.
I have tickets for "Pippin."
I haven't seen it yet.
But from experience,
for example, in "Wicked"
there are certain lines
that you come to expect.
So I'm wondering
how much influence
do you feel from previous
performances of it,
if that performance was 30
years ago or two weeks ago,
that affects you?
Or how much of it
is just, I'm going
to do it the way
I want to do it.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I think
that's the nature of being
a replacement is
that, a lot of times,
where other people have had
workshops, and readings,
and out of town
tryouts, and previews,
and all that sort of thing to
kind of hone your performance,
when you are a replacement, you
are kind of put into the show.
And you go, and it's
kind of like we are still
in our own previews.
So there are lots of things
we're like, OK, that's working.
That can work for
me, so I'm going
to use that because I
know that is working.
But I think Ciara and
I, with every show,
we're already finding
what's working for us.
And there are certain things
that we do that "land" better,
or land at all, that are
different than the people we
replaced.
And there are things
that they will always
do better than we did.
And so sometimes
you abandon that.
And you're like, well,
why do I need that laugh?
I don't need that laugh.
Who said that part
was funny ever?
You can let some
of those things go.
But yeah, it's tricky.
Because we watched the
show for many weeks.
So we had those
things in our head.
So part of it is
just kind of letting
yourself be free
once you get onstage.
Because the audience is
very important in the show.
CIARA RENEE: And I mean, I
think, at the very beginning,
watching it, and getting that
framework, and kind of trying
out those things that they do,
those certain line readings,
or whatever, trying them
out, seeing how they fit,
understanding why
they do it that way.
And then the more you
do it, the more you
get into the character you're
living in the life of the show,
then you start to
make your own choices.
I mean, I don't necessarily
sit down and think,
OK, I'm going to
put the emphasis
on this word, or that word.
I mean, you just kind
of, whatever comes out
of your mouth, whatever
happens, you know what I mean.
And whatever you're
feeling that night.
And I found a lot of
things in the first week
that were like, oh, you can't
really do that differently
because it didn't work at all.
So now, something I do the same
as Patina, and some things I
do completely different.
And I'm finding new
things every day.
So, yeah.
AL SEALES: We've got
a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever get
nervous before the show
starts, or anything?
CIARA RENEE: As
a general rule, I
feel like I don't
get very nervous
because my motto to myself
is, if you're prepared,
there's no reason to be nervous.
And so I just try
to live by that.
However, for this show,
because it is definitely
the biggest thing I've ever
done thus far in my life,
I thought I was going to
throw up on our first night.
I have never been that
nervous ever, ever,
ever because
there's just so much
flying by you at all times.
And you have to be super aware.
Because it is super
dangerous if you mess up.
I mean, you don't
want to do that.
And it's, there's so many lines,
and all this Fosse dancing
that I've never time.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, I was going
to ask you about the Fosse
dancing because you've got
all the acrobatic stuff.
And you've got to get all
the notes and everything.
But then you've got to do this
very precise Fosse routine--
CIARA RENEE: Specific
dance that I only hope
and pray that I'm doing
justice because I did not
have any kind of Fosse training
before going into auditions
for this.
I mean, I danced in college.
But that's not my
strongest suit.
But it's super fun
to do this dance.
It's so much more specific
than I've ever worked before,
and I'm glad to have been taught
this, just like the trapeze.
I never thought
I'd be doing that.
And here, you know?
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah, it's
almost like doing a small card
trick, as opposed to
a huge magic trick.
But I was noticing the precision
that you guys had on that.
And-- it was pretty good.
[LAUGHTER]
CIARA RENEE: Well, thank you.
AL SEALES: Well, it has to be.
MARK DOUGLAS: Yeah?
AL SEALES: It has to be.
It's Fosse.
That's the whole style
is very, very precise.
So yeah, I guess we
have no more questions.
Anybody else?
And we can wrap this up?
Oh.
CIARA RENEE: One more.
AUDIENCE: How are
you guys doing?
CIARA RENEE: Hi.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Good.
AUDIENCE: Is this thing on?
Just because we're at
Google, home of YouTube,
I just want to ask you
guys if you've ever
messed around making any
original content on YouTube
and, if you haven't, for
the acrobatic gentleman,
I'd like to suggest
a channel called
"The Amazing,
Indestructible Acrobat."
You'd get a lot of hits, bro.
CIARA RENEE: That's
your super hero name.
AL SEALES: Would he just
throw things at his chest?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't matter.
When this guy talks,
everybody is like, oh my god!
Oh, he's married?
Eh.
ORION GRIFFITHS:
Well, I actually
have been shooting a documentary
over the last few years.
I'm like, growing
up in the circus,
I didn't go on the
computer very much.
So now I've got the
Facebook and all that stuff.
And I try and go on it at
least once a week, you know.
And everybody is like--
how come you never?
I've got a Twitter, and
I've done three posts.
But it's been eight months.
It's just not how
I-- I grew up family.
We spent time with each other.
And so I'm getting used
to this whole new world.
So I'm shooting
this documentary,
and I'll bring it out soon.
And it's got some
crazy stuff in.
Some crazy stuff.
AUDIENCE: I bet.
ORION GRIFFITHS: Yeah
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I
do a backstage blog
at "Pippin" that's published
on YouTube every Thursday.
[LAUGHTER]
AL SEALES: Where do we find it?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: I don't know.
It's Broadway.com.
CIARA RENEE: Broadway.com, yeah.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: Is
like edited for me
and everything like that.
And I've been
shooting some today
at [INAUDIBLE]
awesome cafeteria.
But yeah, it's called
"Fresh Prince."
AL SEALES: Fresh what?
KYLE DEAN MASSEY:
"Fresh Prince."
Yeah, because I play
a prince in the show.
CIARA RENEE: And he always
catches me without my makeup
on, so thank you for that.
But yeah, for the
show, I have that.
AL SEALES: You can
bring it up here.
KYLE DEAN MASSEY: It's
all the way over there.
AL SEALES: Yeah, that's OK.
We'll wrap this up anyway.
So yeah, everybody, please, give
them another round of applause.
This has been incredible.
[APPLAUSE]